[MUSIC PLAYING]
CALEY SHOEMAKER: Awesome.
So my name is Caylee Shoemaker.
I'm the head distiller
for Hangar 1.
We're up in Alameda, California
on the former Naval Air
Station.
So just up the way.
I'm actually relatively
new to California.
I moved here to join Hangar
1 about three years ago
from Denver, Colorado.
I actually started distilling
at Stranahan's Colorado
Whisky in Denver.
Go Broncos.
I like that shirt.
So I started my
career in whisky.
And the time that I
spent making whisky,
I've really had an opportunity
to learn pretty much
every aspect of
distillation-- everything
from tours and tastings
to grain selection
to mashing, fermenting,
distilling, barrel maturation,
bottling.
There's so many
awesome aspects that
go into making delicious,
delicious beverages.
But when I had the opportunity
to come join Hangar 1 here
in the Bay Area, I
was really excited.
Hangar 1 is a
brand that's really
well-known for using
fresh ingredients
and partnering with
local farmers to source
those ingredients.
And that was
something that I found
really exciting,
intriguing, and that
would be a great challenge.
So here at Hangar
1, where I am now,
working with our
local communities
and local farmers is pretty
much at the center of everything
we do.
We source grain and
wine from local folks.
We work with farmers
throughout California to source
the fruits and botanicals
for our flavored vodka.
And we even get some water
from our friendly neighborhood
fog for fog point.
But we'll talk a little bit
more about that in a bit.
Part of this collaboration
with local suppliers
leads to partnerships with
like-minded individuals.
So Chris is with me here today.
Chris is from FogQuest.
And he'll talk a little
bit about fog and fog water
and how we use
fog to make vodka.
But what we're going to touch
on today is a few things.
We're going to talk a little
bit about innovation in vodka,
innovation in
distilling, and our most
recent innovation at Hangar 1--
Fog Point vodka.
All right.
So before I get too crazy
talking about fog point,
you guys probably would like
to know how vodka is made.
Right?
A lot of people have
this perception of vodka
being a spirit.
That's vodka because
it comes from potatoes.
This is not actually the case.
Vodka can be made from
just about anything.
If it can be fermented
to create alcohol,
it can be made into vodka.
So there are grain
vodkas out there.
There's corn vodka.
There's fruit vodka.
There's even a guy
making vodka from milk.
So people get really
creative with it.
Basically the way to
make vodka is you start
with your fermented material.
And then you need to
distill it to 190 proof.
190 proof is 95% alcohol.
It's pretty spicy stuff, right?
The idea is to reach towards
a clean, odorless, flavorless
profile.
That's actually in the
federal definition.
We don't want it to be 100%
odorless and flavorless.
We want to have a nod to
our starting ingredients.
We put a lot of work into
sourcing really good stuff.
We want you to be
able to taste it.
So the 5% water that sneaks
through with that 95% alcohol
is going to carry through
a little bit of character
from our starting ingredients.
And at Hangar 1, that's
Midwestern grains
and California wine grapes.
So you guys just saw a picture
of the still behind me.
We've also got a
photo right here.
Distilling in a
nutshell is the act
of boiling our
fermented material.
So we're using
California wine grapes.
In our case, that's wine.
And as we boil that material,
the alcohol portion of it
has a lower boiling point
than the water, which
means that the
alcohol steam is going
to rise up off that
solution before the water,
allowing us to collect it and
condense it back down into more
pure liquid alcohol.
Now you see the still behind me.
It's got a lot of little
windows and things on it.
We have to get to 190 proof.
It's a pretty important
part of being vodka.
So that doesn't look
like a whisky still.
That's specifically
a vodka still.
The reason it is
specifically a vodka
still is because the
towers next to the pot
contain a series
of small chambers.
That's what those windows
represent are small chambers.
And in each of those
chambers the vodka
is forced to go from a liquid
to a gas to a liquid to a gas.
Each time leaving
behind more water,
leaving behind impurities,
and making its way
to the collection tanks
at the end at 190 proof.
Now distilling is what
people think about when
they think about making vodka.
Right?
Distilling is the
most important part.
Crazy thing is-- if we're
distilling up to 190 proof,
you guys don't want to drink it
at that high of a proof, right?
So we have to have water.
Water is actually 60% of vodka.
We're going to add water back
into our vodka to bring it down
to that bottle strength.
So there's actually more
water in your alcohol
than there is alcohol
a lot of the times.
Another fun party fact you
can share with your friends.
So for most of our
vodkas-- our straight vodka
and all of our
fruit vodkas-- we're
using reverse osmosis water.
Reverse osmosis
water is so clean
that it allows our
ingredients to shine.
It allows all of the
different nuances
in the flavor profile of
these awesome ingredients
we're using to shine.
And through using
our own water, that
was one of those
things that started
to inspire me to look
at our water usage
and make something
like Fog Point.
I'll get there in a few, though.
I was talking about
our fruit and our wine.
And that's been one
of my favorite parts
of moving from whisky and moving
from Colorado to California
is our collaboration
with our local farmers.
When I first got
here and I saw all
of the really interesting
produce that's
at the farmer's
market year-round,
it inspires us to continue
to make new vodkas.
And our partnership
with those farmers as we
do this is so integral
to everything that we do.
And the drought has had a huge,
huge impact on our farmers.
So this is a really
important time for us
to talk about water and
drought and the water cycle
and its impact on everything
we do in California.
So the drought officially
ended in March.
I know the rain was terrible,
and we're all very tired of it.
But it helped us to get out of
this six-year drought cycle.
That over the course
of the last six years
has caused a lot of
impact on California.
For example, last
year, the drought
cost California $3 million.
And 102 million trees
died over the course
of that six-year drought period.
So that's a little bit
of the impact globally.
But the farmers are really
paying a heavy price
on this drought.
It's important to
remember that California
is an agricultural
center for the US.
It's our biggest
agricultural producer.
There's more than 200
crops grown in California.
So drought and farmers
definitely go hand-in-hand.
The thing that I kept
hearing as we were talking
with our farmers, as
we're sourcing our fruits
for our vodkas is
how the drought
is impacting all of our
fruit quality and our fruit
availability.
Plus, it's impacting me, because
I need water to make my vodka.
Like I said, there's
60% water in vodka.
Water adds to the overall
character of what we're making.
So the final package of a
vodka is that distillate.
You know, it's distilled
up to 190 proof.
Any process that we do.
So any infusion or maceration
of our fruits or botanicals
if we're making a
flavored expression,
and then of course water.
The characteristic of the
water can have a huge impact
on the final product.
So the good news
as we're talking
about water and
these water issues
is that here in
California, as a community,
we like to all innovate as
a group to find solutions
to these problems.
So individuals,
businesses, we're
all committed to chipping in and
making our state a better place
and helping sustainability.
So we tried to do the
same thing at Hangar 1.
As a group, we started looking
for a new, more sustainable
source of water.
What's a way that we could
talk about this issue,
raise awareness for the
water crisis we were having
during the drought, and
make a really tasty vodka
at the same time?
That was our end goal.
So we searched for all kinds
of different processes.
And in that search, someone from
our team came across FogQuest.
Now FogQuest is a nonprofit
that works worldwide
to collect fog for agricultural
and drinking water use.
They work in countries like
Chile, Nepal, Guatemala.
It sounds really cool.
And we realized that fog is so
iconic here in the Bay Area,
the solution for our
water issue was actually
right in front of
us this whole time.
Right?
The question is, could we
actually use fog to make vodka?
Sounds like a really cool idea.
Is it actually
something we can do?
So we decided to reach out
to the experts at FogQuest.
So Chris here is our
local fog expert.
Chris has been volunteering
with FogQuest for the last four
years.
And he has been instrumental
in this project for us.
We've actually learned so much
visiting the fog collectors
with Chris, and
learning about how
fog is created in California,
and how is a way that we
might be able to collect it.
So Chris, tell us a little
bit about fog, please.
CHRIS FOGLIATTI: Excellent Hi.
Like Caley said, I'm a volunteer
with the charity FogQuest
Sustainable Water Solutions.
And FogQuest's mission
is to provide water
to people in remote
locations using fog.
And right now,
FoqQuest has projects
in eight countries supplying
significant amounts of water.
Like Caley said,
they brought me here
to explain a little
bit about the fog,
because it's kind
of bewildering.
And I want to try to explain
how this mechanism works.
And the first question I want
to answer is, what is the fog?
And out here in the Bay Area,
the most prolific kind of fog
that we see is the
fog from the ocean,
the fog comes off the ocean.
And that is technically
called advection fog.
And advection means movement.
And so the way the fog is
generated from the ocean
is warm air moves
across the cool ocean.
And as that air is cooled,
it cannot hold as much water.
So the air becomes
supersaturated.
And then as the air
cools even further,
water droplets are formed.
So that's the mechanism
for generating ocean fog.
This ocean fog is
the starting point
for fog collection
in most areas.
And in one area where FogQuest
has the largest network of fog
collectors-- it's in a
remote village in Guatemala--
the advection fog is
the starting point.
In this village FogQuest has
around 35 large fog collectors.
And that occupies a
collection surface
of around 15,000 square feet.
So that's about a third of
a football field vertically
posted like billboards.
And those collectors produce
around 1,800 gallons of water
a day during the dry season.
This network by FogQuest,
it's a minimalist network.
It's designed to be
rather inexpensive.
And also it's a
passive technology.
And so it doesn't
require any energy.
And so for the people
in this one village,
the fog is a very positive
aspect in their life.
Now out here in the
Bay Area, people
have a little more mixed
feelings about the fog.
Sometimes the fog will cause
traffic delays or airport
delays.
But also during the
summertime, the fog
can cool off an entire
city or an entire county.
And so if you think
about it, for the fog
to have an impact
over a square mile,
there's a lot of
energy in the fog.
There's a lot of cold water.
It's just difficult
to acquire that water.
So I hope that
helps a little bit.
Now the process
for fog collection
is pretty straightforward.
What has to happen
is fog has to be
blown through a mesh
for several hours.
And then water is
trapped on the mesh.
And it's eventually
collected in a tank.
So I want to explain a little
bit more about why this works.
And the starting
point to understanding
why this system works is I
can explain a little bit more
about fog.
And the most important aspect of
fog is that the droplets in fog
are microscopic.
They are about 100 times
smaller than a raindrop.
So raindrops, their trajectory
usually is vertical.
They're falling from
the cloud to the ground.
Fog droplets tend to float.
They move horizontally.
So fog collectors will be
posted in a vertical fashion
to try to maximize the fog
going through the material.
So the process, like I said,
it's pretty straightforward.
Fog droplets impact the mesh.
Then they get trapped,
and they start moving.
And over time, the mesh
becomes waterlogged.
And then larger droplets fall
from the mesh into a trough,
and then into a collection tank.
So basically what these
fog collectors are doing
is they're converting the small,
microscopic droplets in fog
into larger droplets, which
we can then plumb into a tank.
And one tool that
fog researchers use
is called the standard
fog collector.
A standard fog collector can
measure the fog collection
efficiency in a particular area.
And last year for the
fog vodka project,
we mainly used these
standard fog collectors.
Also, the researchers
commonly use them.
And from June through September,
this one small fog collector
averaged over a gallon a day,
produced over a gallon a day
during the fog season
at Sutro Tower.
Now these standard
fog collectors,
because researchers
use them, they're
made to standard specifications
and standard sizes.
The main component
on a fog collector
is one square meter metal frame.
And then that metal frame is
wrapped in a specific type
of shade cloth.
There's two layers
of shade cloth
that go over the metal frame.
That makes up the
fog collection panel.
Then the fog collection
panel is lifted two meters
off the ground.
It's also anchored in
place with guy wires.
The shade cloth that we use
for the standard fog collectors
was studied for around 10 years.
And this particular shade
cloth with a Raschel weave
and a 35% shade
coefficient was determined
to be the most optimum
material for fog
collection at high elevations.
And if you look at
the shape cloth,
it's a little hard
to see right here,
but the Raschel weave
forms a triangle.
And that facilitates water
shedding off the material.
And also, that
triangle pattern is
similar to the branch and needle
structure on redwood trees.
It's very similar.
So there's a lot of biomimicry
going on in fog collection.
And a big topic of
research is a lot
of researchers in schools are
trying to develop materials
which are more efficient than
the standard fog collection
material.
And for this project
for this upcoming year
we have several standard fog
collectors that we're using.
And we're also using
a larger fog collector
with one of these
more exotic materials.
So it'll be interesting
to see what happens.
CALEY SHOEMAKER:
So we learned a ton
from working with
FogQuest and Chris.
And it turns out that fog
collection is actually
like the perfect Bay Area
solution to our Bay Area water
problem.
So we worked with Chris
and FogQuest to build
and strategically placed
these fog collectors
throughout the Bay.
Now Chris is monitoring three
fog collectors at Sutro Tower.
This is actually a photo
of one of our collectors
you can see at the
base of the tower.
And then we have a fog farm
that was recently installed
at a farm in Half Moon Bay.
Chris, can you tell us why
fog collectors at Sutro Tower
make sense?
CHRIS FOGLIATTI: Sure.
Yeah.
Well, to do fog
collection successfully,
it does require a
very specific set
of geographic
characteristics be met.
And one thing that's a
little counterintuitive
is we're using the advection
fog-- the ocean fog.
But the main criteria
that FogQuest requires
is the fog collectors should be
placed at around 2/3 the height
of the fog bank.
So in the Bay Area, that means
generally around 1,000 feet up.
And this is because the
fog collection is passive,
an additional condensation
step is required.
And as the fog from the
ocean travels up the hill,
more condensation occurs.
And the fog becomes
more water dense.
So that's one requirement.
Another requirement is
proximity to the ocean.
It's generally recommended
that the fog collectors should
be installed within
five miles of the ocean.
And another requirement
is generally
a free path for the fog to
go from the ocean to the net.
Now these characteristics
in the Bay Area
are very difficult
to reach, because we
have real estate and vegetation
that's always occupying space.
So it's really a
matter of compromises.
Other important
factors that we look
at when we're seeing if
fog collecting will work
is if there's a
change in the plant
ecology, if there is really lush
green ferns, or a lot of moss
on a tree during
the summertime, it's
pretty likely there's going
to be fog in that area.
Also, you can use just
physical examples.
Like if you're driving
through an area
and you have to turn on your
windshield wipers, that's
an area that has a lot of fog.
And another cue is from nature.
We can study the fog drift
that comes off the trees.
And if there is a significant
amount of water under a tree,
that's a good clue that
fog collection will work.
And really to combine all
these characteristics,
I've noticed that one
tool the researchers use
is Google Earth,
because it can pull up
the elevation, the
proximity to the ocean.
And you can see the obstacles.
So that's pretty interesting.
CALEY SHOEMAKER: Awesome.
So last summer, Sutro
Tower's fog collectors
were able to collect about 350
gallons during the high fog
season.
So just a little idea of
how much water we can get.
So it's now time for a little
bit of audience participation.
You guys have all
got a vial with you.
This is a sample of the water
collected at Sutro Tower
over the last couple of days.
So I'd like to take
this opportunity
to taste this fog water
so we can understand
how the flavor of this water
impacts the final flavor
profile of the vodka.
And we'll taste the
vodka in just a moment.
So go ahead and give
this water a sip.
So the water's collected.
It's brought to the
hangar in tanks.
We then carbon
filter it, boil it,
and carbon filter
it a second time.
Now the filtration step
is really important,
because we are collecting fog
and these nice beautiful nature
areas that have things
like leaves and dust
that might be able to
fall into the fog tank.
So we want to remove any
of those particulates.
We then boil to ensure
the water is sanitary,
and just filter one more time to
make sure it's nice and clean.
Once we've been
through these steps,
we send the water out to
the laboratory for analysis.
And it turns out that
the fog water is actually
cleaner than the average
tap water in the Bay Area.
However, as you
guys are tasting it,
you'll notice it does have
its own character to it.
So the thing that I really
like about the water
is that mineral note
that you get there.
It reminds me a lot of hiking.
I'm really into hiking.
And when you are outside
on a nice warm day
after a damp morning or
a rainstorm, and you can
smell the warm, wet stones
of like river or something
as you're crossing by.
That's exactly what the
fog water reminds me of.
It also has a slight salty
mineral characteristic to it.
I don't know if that
comes from the ocean.
I like to think that it does.
Awesome.
So we've talked a
lot about the water.
What are we distilling
to make this vodka?
We're using wine.
We decided to partner with
Bonny Doon Vineyards, because we
decided if we're going to
make this a sustainable vodka,
is we're going to do this,
we want to really do it.
Now Randall Graham and
the Bonny Doon team
really inspired me with
their wine-making techniques.
They're huge into sustainable
biodynamic farming.
When I'm talking about
biodynamic farming,
I'm talking about synchronizing
the viticultural process
with the natural cycles of
the plants and of nature,
so that it's a low-impact,
natural way to farm.
Things like bringing in
symbiotic plants and animals
to augment the growing
conditions of the grapes
instead of using artificial
elements-- things
like fertilizers and pesticides.
So we have these really great,
sustainable, delicious grapes
that are turned into a
wine, as Randall puts it,
with minimal human intervention.
So we worked with the entire
2012 vintage of Bonny Doon's Le
Cigare Blanc wine.
This is a white
wine blend that's
made of Picpoul, Roussanne,
and Grenache Blanc.
We brought all of the
wine to the distillery
and distilled it
up to 190 proof,
and then used nothing but
pure California fog water
to cut that vodka
back down to 80 proof.
And poof-- Fog Point vodka.
This delicious stuff
that you guys all
happen to have a taste of.
So now the moment
you've been waiting for.
We've been talking all morning.
You're here to taste vodka.
So when I'm tasting a vodka, I
like to start with nosing it.
It gives my mind and
my palate a preview
of what's about to happen.
You guys don't
need to swirl this.
I know we're all very
used to wine tasting.
But there's a lot
more alcohol in here
than there is in a wine.
And swirling it is going to
make that volatile alcohol
rise above the surface.
So when you nose it, you'll
get less of the lovely notes
and a lot more alcohol.
So no swirling.
But go ahead and take a nose.
Breathe in through your nose
and mouth at the same time.
That aerates that alcohol
scent a little bit
so you can start to notice
the characteristics coming off
of the vodka.
Now you can smell
that mineraliness
you get from the water.
But there's also a little
bit of floral characteristic,
also a little bit of sweetness.
Next, go ahead and take a
small sip from your vodka.
This is going to prime
your palate and cleanse it.
Saw some of you guys
eating salads back there.
Don't want your vodka
to taste like salad.
So this step will go ahead
and cleanse and get you ready.
And on the next sip, take
a slightly larger sip,
and allow yourself
to really experience
the texture of the vodka,
the nice round mouth feel.
And all those flavor notes
will start to come out.
Floral notes, sweetness.
Making a vodka from
100% wine was something
I was really excited to do.
Our straight vodka combines
the grain and great profile
to make a really interesting,
complex expression.
But so much of that
sweetness and that softness
comes from the grain.
So to have 100%
grape vodka makes
for a really-- dare I say--
robust flavored vodka.
All right.
After vodka tasting,
a little bit of fun
factoids about Fog Point.
So we used a vintage wine
and all the fog water we
could collect for six months.
And in doing that,
we were able to make
2,472 bottles of Fog Point.
So this is a really
limited edition vodka.
We released it here in
California and in a couple
select areas
throughout the country.
And the response was awesome.
It was really exciting to
see spirits nerds and people
that are really into the
distilling industry like it.
But to see average people
really getting into it too.
Everyone across
the board thought
this was a really cool idea.
And I think it really
brought forth a conversation
about water conservation
and collecting fog.
We created our bar programs
to different bartenders
throughout the country to
make some Fog Point Martinis.
We actually just
enjoyed one right
by the Bay Bridge over there
at EPIC Steak House yesterday.
Really delicious way
to taste the vodka.
And that salty characteristic
makes it pair really
well with seafood,
which is perfect,
because we have a lot of
that here in the Bay Area.
The last fun note is that we've
donated the profits from Fog
Point sales back to FogQuest
and to other water conservation
organizations to push this
conversation forward and help
facilitate more research into
how fog collection could become
a viable solution for
some of this water crisis
that we've been experiencing.
And I understand that it really
has pushed the conversation
forward.
CHRIS FOGLIATTI: Yes.
Because of this
project, I've been
introduced to numerous
groups of researchers.
And they're interested more
in talking with Hangar 1,
because they're so
supportive of that community.
But we've also met some
businesses that are using fog.
I'll talk about them in a bit.
But some of the researchers
that Hangar 1 has now
been associated with
are out of the USGS.
Alicia Torregrosa.
She works in the Western
Regional Science Center
down the street at Menlo Park.
And one aspect of
her research is
to compile satellite
data over several years
during the summertime.
And she overlays
those satellite images
and is able to get an estimate
of the approximate fog
and low coastal cloud
concentrations in an area.
This is a good starting
point for fog researchers.
And this map is of
the Point Reyes area.
If you're familiar
with the North Bay,
you can see that
the white parts are
kind of in the Marin headlands,
and then up by Point Reyes.
And once again, if
we were to cross
this map with the
other characteristics,
especially using
Google Earth, we're
able to pinpoint
locations much better.
Other researchers
that we've met include
ecologists and botanists.
Some ecologists are studying
the fog drip off of trees.
And they found that
in some locations,
especially on the ridge
line above Half Moon Bay
that the fog drip
off the trees can
account for twice as
much water as comes
during the rainy season.
This image here is an image
from Alicia Torregrosa's
standard fog collectors up
in the mid-peninsula research
area.
And what she has there
is-- like I said,
researchers are trying to
study different mesh to see
which ones are more effective.
And so she has an array up.
And there's going to be a
journal article out shortly
combining this evaluation along
with several other evaluations
along the coast of California.
But what's really
fascinating is we
met a botanist who was doing
research out of Santa Barbara.
And she set up some
standard fog collectors
at a strawberry farm and
other biology type equipment.
And she was able to measure
how efficiently plants were
transporting water and
doing photosynthesis.
And she was able to
prove that after a fog
event at these particular
strawberry farms,
the strawberries required
less water to thrive.
And that's really
interesting, especially
if we combine that fact with
Alicia Torregrosa's maps, where
they show that
Salinas Valley where
there's a lot of these
lettuce and strawberry farms--
that's prime fog area.
So there's a lot of
interesting studies of fog,
not really related to
collecting the water.
But ecologists are studying it
and botanists are studying it.
And also toxicologists
are studying it.
So now some of the businesses
we've met with this project
include a guy who sold Hangar
1 the first ever fog collector
of this style in
the United States.
We met Michael Donahue
with this company Fog2H2O.
And he is a distributor of this
German-engineered style fog
collector, which has been
trademarked and branded
the Cloud Fisher fog collectors.
They use, like I say,
a more exotic mesh.
And also they have an
aspect of German engineering
where they're more robust than
the FogQuest fog collectors.
But there's also more money
involved in the materials.
So it's interesting to see the
different charities compete.
One's a highly
engineered device.
And one's more of a
minimalist device.
Now those collectors that
we saw have been installed
successfully in Morocco.
And in 2018 with the support of
a couple of Moroccan charities
and the support of
a German government,
these Cloud Fisher
style fog collectors
are estimated to be the new
largest fog collector network.
They're supposed to be larger
than the one FogQuest has
up in Guatemala.
So it will be interesting to
see if they can accomplish that
by 2018.
So through talking
with these researchers
and these businesses, I
really think that Fog Point
has established a dialogue.
And we think it will be
interesting to see where
we go forward from here with
water conservation and fog
studies and the
work on the farms.
CALEY SHOEMAKER: Very cool.
Awesome.
So a little bit in closing.
I hope you guys can see that
innovation and fresh thinking
are at the center of pretty much
everything we do at Hangar 1.
So we were so excited
to be invited to Google.
Google is thought of as a really
progressive company that's
on the forefront of human
ingenuity, I would say.
And so it's really
exciting to be
able to come here and talk
to you guys about Fog Point.
I hope I've changed
your perception of what
you're drinking.
So next time you're
out at happy hour,
you can think about how
much water is in this vodka
and where did it come from?
We do welcome your
thoughts, though.
We're always innovating.
We're always
looking for new ways
to make vodka and new
things to make vodka from.
So please feel free to reach
out to me if you guys have
any ideas about any sort of fun
projects we could go forth on
and any issues we can address
in the vodka-making world.
And also lastly, I'd like
to invite all of you--
we passed a little card.
But please come visit
us at the distillery.
We're located just up the way at
the Alameda Naval Air Station.
And we'd love to have you so
you can see our equipment,
learn about our process, taste
Fog Point, Hangar 1, and some
of our limited edition vodkas.
So thank you very much.
I'd like to open
it up for questions
if anyone has any questions.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CALEY SHOEMAKER: That's
a great question.
CHRIS FOGLIATTI:
Well, like I said,
the researchers
from Stanford are
trying to study the
characteristics which
produce a lot of fog drift.
And so they were at
that stage in 2015.
I know the research is ongoing.
Now, I'm not sure
what you mean by what
the impact on the ecosystem is.
What the researchers are
able to do other than study
the fog drift is
they're able to do
an isotope analysis of the
water table from well water.
And they can identify
how much of the water
recently came from fog
and how much of the water
came from rain.
And there has been, once
again, in some watersheds,
especially along the coast--
I'm talking about the Crystal
Springs watershed just east
of Half Moon Bay--
the isotope analysis
of that water table
shows that the fog has a
very significant impact
on that watershed.
Yeah.
Well, that's a good question.
Of course, if you were to
layer fog nets everywhere,
it could have an impact.
But generally the
fog is so spread out,
and it does encompass
such a high and wide area,
that it would be difficult to
remove a large amount of water.
But an obvious thing
to do-- and the reason
I think that the USGS is
involved in mapping this out
is they could potentially
regulate it and set up
a permit system.
So people are removing the
water in a sustainable manner.
AUDIENCE: Isn't the fog
that you get near the Bay,
wouldn't it have salt in it?
CHRIS FOGLIATTI:
Well, certainly there
is an impact on the fog from
the wave-breaking action.
And that does introduce
different chemicals
into the fog.
Now as the fog
travels up a hill--
like I say, FogQuest recommends
installing the fog nets
at a high elevation.
Most of the impurities
in the fog drop out.
And in order to provide water
to these remote communities,
the fog water had to be tested.
And it's been
tested for decades.
And it most generally
meets the criteria set
by the UN for clean
water, especially
compared to groundwater in some
of these more remote areas.
But yeah.
There is an impact there.
And it's due mainly
to the wave action.
That's the point of exposure.
That's where the fog changes
characteristics is right
when it crosses the beach.
AUDIENCE: How much water
does a single catcher get
on a good day, I guess?
CHRIS FOGLIATTI:
Sutro Tower I think
is a good optimum
location in the Bay Area.
And last summer during
our heavy fog period,
it averaged just over
a gallon per day.
And that's one square meter.
Usually Usually they're
measured in gallons--
or liters per day
per square meter.
So a little over
four liters per day.
CALEY SHOEMAKER: We put up
a standard fog collector
at the distillery
in Alameda as well,
mainly because people
want to see them.
But also we were kind of
interested in how much water
we would collect.
We get about a half
liter a day, maybe
a liter on a really good day.
So we use it to
help water plants.
But we're not in an optimal
area like Sutro Tower.
AUDIENCE: Does the distillery
make any naturally flavored
vodkas?
CALEY SHOEMAKER: Yes.
All of our vodkas are
naturally flavored.
So any of our flavored
bunches that you will taste
are made by macerating fruits
and botanicals in 190 proof
spirit.
We then save that infusion
and take the fruit out.
If you've ever made
infused vodka at home,
you know that when you
take the fruit out,
you have really
boozy fruit left.
Right?
We don't want to let
that alcohol go to waste.
So we take the fruit and
we put it back into our pot
still with a little water, and
then distill the alcohol out
of the fruit.
And during that
process, whatever
oils and compounds that
were in our botanicals
that the alcohol
couldn't pull out,
the heat from the still
breaks down and pulls through
in that distillate.
That distillate and
infusion are then
used to flavor the final vodka.
And so that's why our
vodkas taste so fresh.
We work with our farmers
at the peak of freshness.
They deliver all of
the fruit for the year.
So for example, when
we do Buddha's Hands,
they're in season
December-January.
I'm in Buddha Hand
land during that time.
And then I don't touch Buddha's
Hands for the rest of the year.
So we do all of our infusions
and distillates more seasonally
like a winery, and then
blend and batch them
throughout the air so that we do
have that fresh-flavored vodka.
AUDIENCE: Where can you buy it?
That's the question.
So Fog Point did
sell very quickly.
It was so popular.
It is sold out
almost everywhere.
There is a shop located
at the distillery that
has a few bottles left.
And as far as I know,
those are the last few.
The good news is that with
Chris's help and our new fog
farm, we're working on another
expression of Fog Point.
It will be a little bit
different than the current one.
We're collecting fog
from a different area.
So there may be a slightly
different flavor profile there.
And we're exploring what
other types of wine we
might be able to use as well.
Any other questions, guys?
AUDIENCE: How much does the
standard fog catcher cost?
CALEY SHOEMAKER: Oh,
that's a great question.
CHRIS FOGLIATTI:
Yeah, well, like I
said, the materials using the
FogQuest design like the one I
showed up at Sutro Tower,
they use an ABS post
system to hold them up.
So it's relatively inexpensive.
Around $300.
And the academics
use steel posts.
They're a little more expensive.
Now that's not including
any measurement equipment.
Usually the SFC array I showed
that Alicia had up here,
it had tipping bucket
rain gauges on there
where they can
monitor in real time
how much the water
is being produced.
That adds another
$300 or $400 per unit.
So it can get expensive.
But the idea is that these
can be assembled by people
who have few resources.
So it should be
relatively feasible.
CALEY SHOEMAKER: As
I understand it, too,
once we've determined an area
is good for fog collection,
it's very easy to put in an
expensive fog collector there,
because they know they're
going to get good fog.
Right?
CHRIS FOGLIATTI: Yeah.
The first step is to put
a smaller one up, test it,
verify, and then go larger.
AUDIENCE: So speaking
about fog, and I
guess there's a certain
height of the fog.
Like, it won't go past a
certain altitude or whatever.
Is that taken into
consideration when you're
making the fog collectors?
Is there an optimal height of
the fog collector that you've
seen and the ones
that are produced,
being that maybe
if it's too tall,
it will evaporate
before it gets collected
or something like that?
CHRIS FOGLIATTI: Yeah, well,
certainly the fog collectors--
both the standard fog
collectors and larger collection
nets, it's important to
have them a couple of meters
off the ground, because
there's a boundary layer
right on the ground.
And there's a lot
of fluid dynamics
involved in fog collection.
And the fluid
dynamics-- people say
that the closer to the
ground you get, the more poor
the performance is.
So there's that question.
And so they're usually about
2 meters off the ground.
And this larger system we had,
it went to about three meters
up after that.
And like I say, in order to
find the optimum elevation,
generally you don't try
and raise the fog net
up to the elevation, you try
and get the right height land,
and then just put it
two or three meters up.
Cause it's a lot easier
to construct than trying
to raise it really high up.
But there are opportunities
to install fog collectors
on rooftops.
But then those are much higher.
But then you have another
fluid dynamic problem
where the fog hits the
building, and it kind of
shoots over the top.
So we're involved
with fluid dynamics.
People are trying to create a
spoiler or something that will
force the fog into the net.
But that's a
problem that's going
to take several decades,
probably, to solve.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
How is the vodka affected,
if at all, by geographically
where the fog is collected?
CALEY SHOEMAKER: That's
a great question.
So for the Fog Point
that we tasted today,
we collected fog from
a couple of locations,
including Berkeley,
Tilden Park, Sutro Tower.
And we had a few collectors
for a while in the Presidio.
Because we were so
new to collecting fog,
and because we were collecting
such small amounts day by day,
we added them all
to the same tank.
So the flavor
profile of the fog is
how I know the flavor
profile of the fog to be.
And I never had the
opportunity to taste
the fog from
different collectors
separately until just recently.
I'm finding that the
water is very similar.
But there definitely is a
little bit of shift from place
to place.
I never thought I would
talk about fog terroir
at this point in my career.
But, you know, it happened.
So yes.
The flavor difference
is very minor I'm
finding here in California.
But I'd be really interested to
see how fog water might taste
different in
Guatemala or Morocco
than what we can get here
in northern California.
AUDIENCE: So I wanted
to know if there's
a way for you to tell us
how long does it usually
takes before a new
flavor of vodka comes up.
Or in this case, when you
develop the Fog one vodka,
how long did this whole
planning process happen
from beginning to the end?
CALEY SHOEMAKER: That's
a great question.
So we do a lot of
experimentation
at the distillery.
I often find myself going
to the farmer's market
and finding some really
awesome fruit or botanical
we want to play with.
So there's always
this sort of research
new product development time
involved where we really
want to dial in
the vodka itself,
how delicious it's going to be.
Once we get to
that point, there's
a lot of other things involved--
things like package design,
the federal government
has to approve our
labels, things like that.
So it can take quite a while to
get all those things together
and to get the bottling
materials in and whatnot.
But it does vary from
product to product.
Some take a lot
less time to plan.
Fog Point, unfortunately,
took quite a while,
because we had the lead time
to collect all this water.
So it was kind of an
ongoing experiment for us
and a really
exciting day when we
had the opportunity to
actually say, here's the vodka.
Here it is.
Go out and taste it, guys.
AUDIENCE: So the question is,
what is your advice for someone
interested in becoming
a master distiller?
What education avenues
would you recommend?
CALEY SHOEMAKER: That's a
really awesome question,
because I got into distilling
a little bit by mistake,
if you will.
I'm very lucky that I
found my passion this way.
I have an art degree.
And it was during
a gap in employment
that I was looking for
something fun to do
and stumbled upon distilling.
I was really into craft
beer, so it drove me there.
But I never knew how
much I'd love distilling
and how interesting the
science of distilling would be.
I'm hoping seeing more people
out doing things like growing
distilling wine-making drives
people towards STEM a little
bit more, because I think
understanding science
and engineering is
really helpful--
chemistry especially
as a distiller.
But there is a lot
of art involved.
So people from all walks of life
are involved in this industry.
And there's a lot that folks
can contribute from anywhere.
So I say if you're interested
in distilling or learning
to distill, just get
out there and learn.
Read as much as you can.
And involve yourself
in the industry.
Because you never
know when there's
going to be a job opportunity
and an opportunity to learn.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
CALEY SHOEMAKER:
Thank you, guys.
SPEAKER 1: round of applause.
CALEY SHOEMAKER: Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]